In 2016, a fierce, Indigenous-led movement emerged at Standing Rock. The world
watched while a powerful oil company and police teamed up to unleash violence on
protesters. Ultimately, the pipeline
company won. Now, Energy Transfer Partners
is extending that pipeline to Louisiana.
And another resistance is brewing. This
time, it's out in the swamps of Cajun
country, across Indigenous lands and
waterways, and in communities of color.
Waging war on Big Oil isn't easy, but
people here are not going down without a fight.
Oil and gas is king in Louisiana.
We are gonna fight every inch of this pipeline going into the ground in whatever way we can.
They're profiting off of our pain.
My fight is clean water, clean soil and clean air.
Activists here call the pipeline the “black snake.”
We call it kicking the snake in its a**.
We're driving across Louisiana to talk to the people affected and
see what they're doing to resist. Our
first stop: Indian Bayou.
This is the land of refugees and survivors and thrivers.
I’m with Cherri Foytlin, who runs the L'eau Est La Vie (louie la vie) protest camp,
which means “Water Is Life.” They travel to different locations to disrupt pipeline construction.
We're resisting one of the largest Goliath-type beasts in the world, which
is the oil and gas industry. It didn't
start at Standing Rock that people were
fighting, especially Indigenous people.
Indigenous mothers and grandmothers have
been fighting for ourselves and for this
land, and for the water and the safety of
the people who live here, for generations
upon generations upon generations. Energy
Transfer Partners has spilled every 11
days on average for the past 15 years.
The camp bought an 11-acre piece of land in the pipeline's path, which serves as
its headquarters. The pipeline company
was forced to change its plans and reroute
around the camp because of the holdout. Protesters have had run-ins with police and pipeline security.
The intimidation has been pretty intense at times. There is some sort of shadowy group that's around, that's in
very dark, tinted cars.
I'll be in Piggly-Wiggly and they'll be taking
pictures of me and my kids, you know, shopping for food. Or they'll be outside my house or whatever.
[Police] stop us for a traffic ticket with their guns drawn it's almost like they want to see something happen.
Just being at camp is pretty difficult. It’s 98 degrees right now and oppressively humid.
It's the mosquitoes you got to worry about, because they will eat you up.
Since colonization happened, Indigenous
peoples here in Louisiana, what's now
called Louisiana, were pushed back
further and further into the swamps, and
not only did they find a way to thrive there,
they also found a way to resist there. It is a gorgeous place worth protecting, and
there's so much more to protect. I
worry about the idea that it's
all gone, that it's all refineries and chemical plants.
Our next stop is out in Cajun Country, where a huge point of contention is the pipeline running
through the Atchafalaya Basin, the
biggest wetlands area in the United
States. Many Cajun people, like Jody Meche, depend on it to make a living. He's suing the
Army Corps of Engineers for allowing ETP to come into the basin, given the damage past pipelines have done.
These people make billions and billions of
dollars, and there's no reason why they
should destroy such a sensitive
ecosystem and a sensitive world we live in. You know what I'm saying? I'm telling y'all,
when I get a trap full of dead crawfish, that ain't no good. It's an indication of like the canary in the mine shaft.
Jody has been fishing here all his life.
It was a trade that was passed down by
his father and his grandfather before that.
That’s what it’s all about. There's too much at stake.
There's people's livelihoods at
stake, there's numerous species of fish
and birds, I mean, all types of marine
animals that survive out here. The Cajun
people and the Cajun way of life, we were
born and we followed our parents and
watched them do their living, by fishing
and making their way of life in the
Atchafalaya Basin, you know, catching fish, crawfish, hunting stuff to eat. And you
adapt to that way of life. You're born into that.
A judge put a temporary halt on pipeline construction due to Jody's case. The ruling was appealed and
now construction is back on.
This is the newly cleared right-of-way for the Bayou Bridge pipeline.
I'm worried about the risk of a 20-inch oil pipeline potentially obstructing – and leaking.
Should that oil leak to a capacity that it spreads across these thousands of acres
of critical habitat, I mean, you definitely have a major disaster.
Oil companies have changed the Atchafalaya Basin
already. They clear large areas of trees,
and bore down into the swamp bottom.
The excess dirt dams up certain areas and creates pockets of dead swamp where nothing can survive.
There's creatures that are relying on
this water. It should have been better
taken care of than what it was. And I
want to make sure that it's done better
in the future so we don't continue to
lose areas like what we've lost. And none
of those creatures can give
interviews or can go to
legislatures and cry out to the
people who are supposed to be doing the
job to represent the environment and
represent the people and represent them.
Another issue, which is all too real in
Louisiana: flooding. Dredging has caused
sediment buildup, and the basin now has
less capacity to hold floodwaters.
The water, as it comes into the basin, it has
to go higher up on the levee systems,
putting our levee systems, which
are not up to par, at greater risk of
breaching or topping and flooding
millions of people in countless
communities. We're not opposed to the oil and
gas industry, we're not opposed to your
jobs, your jobs being
related to the oil and gas industry. We just
know the job can be done better.
75 miles east, there's another waterway that could be seriously damaged.
We're meeting with Monique Verdin, a
tribal councilman for the Houma Nation.
This water body behind me, the Bayou Lafourche, provides over 300,000 people
south of here with their drinking water,
their bathing water, their everything
water. This really is the lifeline for
the United Houma Nation.
The Houma dodged the Trail of Tears by going deep into the delta, to the ends of the bayous,
where they had everything they needed because they were able to provide for themselves.
If the pipeline were to burst, or if there was
to be an accident, that's not only the
water for the Bayou Lafourche, that's the
water for everybody in New Orleans.
That's the water for everybody south of New Orleans.
Monique is part of a coalition of
Indigenous women who focus on divestment,
so they urge big banks to stop funding
companies that build pipelines on sacred land.
When you look at this legacy of
colonialism here and then you follow the
pipeline money, it leads back to Europe,
to these big banks that are investing in
these corporations.
At the endpoint of the pipeline, our final stop is the town of St. James, where residents are pushing back.
Harry Joseph, who pastors a tiny Baptist
church, is, like Jody, suing the pipeline company.
The Bayou Bridge pipeline, you saw how they twisted and how they turned it.
Till they got to St. James, through a lot of black areas, through a lot of Hispanic areas, a lot of Indians.
They ain't went through none of the white folks' area.
For years, oil and gas companies have run rampant on this low-income black community. People live with huge
fuel tanks in their backyards. Refineries and pipelines are everywhere.
They need to move up the road somewhere, and let people there store their oil,
because it ain't going to get here. I'll make sure of that. We got enough tanks in now. We got 118
tanks. That's enough.
But with the Bayou Bridge pipeline, that
mean more tanks. That mean more oil is going to be stored here. That mean more
leaks going to be here. That mean that more smell's going to be here. You know,
we got oil leaking now and nobody want to take the responsibility.
St. James is in the heart of Cancer Alley, a stretch of Louisiana with
some of the highest rates of cancer rates in the country.
Eventually, if you stay here, you going to die. My church is a family. I
don't look at my members as my members, I look at them as my family, because we
are very close. And one of my members is
sickly. She got cancer. So that's why I'm
involved, because when my people hurt, I
hurt. When my people suffer, I suffer.
Previous pipeline companies have closed off a road that served as an evacuation route
for a part of the community.
People worry if there was leak or
explosion, they would have no way out.
This is not a want. This is a need. We need
an evacuation route. I'm going to fight, I'm gonna do whatever I got to do. But I don't
think we can overcome, because once you let one in, and you let another one in,
and you let another one in, and you let a Bayou Bridge pipeline in, you done let too much come in already.
Louisiana already has over 50,000
miles of pipelines, and they're second
only to Texas in refineries. While the
industry props up their economy, they
also have the most to lose to the
effects of climate change, which is
caused by these fossil fuel industries.
We lose a football field of land
every 45 minutes in south Louisiana. And
any land that goes into water becomes
property of the state, and the state
leases it back to the oil and gas industry.
One third of the nation's oil and gas is either being produced or transported via south Louisiana. But I
always like to remind people that we're
the best-worst example. When it comes to
poverty in America, we're at the top of
the list. When it comes to quality
education and healthcare, we're at the
bottom of the list.
Louisiana has powered all of the United States – to great sacrifice of ourselves. We, at
this point, are like a stage-four lung
cancer patient that's continuing to
smoke. You know, it's time to make that
change so that we are actually able to survive.